from a Christmas Pizza to reindeer cake
pops we wanted to compare all the fast
food Christmas menu items in the UK and
the US this is food Wars
happy holidays everyone I'm supposed to
be a Christmas tree according to Target
I think I look more like a decorative
frog man three two one at the McDonald's
in the U.S this holiday season you can
get a smoky Double Quarter Pounder with
cheese BLT a smoky BLT quarter pounder
with cheese and this Oreo McFlurry we'll
start with the regular Smoky BLT quarter
pounder with cheese
how's that first of all chill out with
the tomatoes second of all what do we
think internet is this a generous
portion of bacon yay wow two slices of
cheese dough does the quarter pounder
always come with two slices of cheese
I'm curious what makes this thing so
smoky
that's very good actually it has like a
barbecue flavor to it if that's not
enough meat for you look what we got
here a Double Quarter Pounder so half
pounder peel the cat back
I mean there is not a tomato supply
chain issue in this country that's for
sure there's even less bacon for the
devil I feel like this is too much meat
but they did put a piece of cheese in
between the two patties of meat and I
appreciate that
too much what better to wash this tasty
burger down than an Oreo fudge McFlurry
of all the things to be grateful for
the fact that the nearby McDonald's ice
cream machine was working tapping the
list right now
the Oreo shakes the Oreo McFlurries the
Oreo anything a fast food places might
be the best one because it isn't vanilla
it's like the Oreo cream flavored with
the cookies oh man this is so good
McDonald's in the UK has a bunch of
festive exclusives we'll start with a
breakfast festive item which honestly
I'm not actually convinced is
particularly festive this is a mighty
muffin I'm not trying to be a grinch
here I'm not trying to ruin Christmas
for anybody at least of all McDonald's
however can someone please explain to me
how a sausage bacon and egg McMuffin
with cheese is in any way festive
whatsoever
these also come as two options you can
get this one which is with ketchup or
there is an option with brown sauce
moving on for breakfast now we're on to
the mains let's start with these the big
tasty burgers
not the most creative name but one that
kind of gets to the point which I
respect I like the packaging of these
they come in these festive green and red
little bow and gift tags they're pretty
cute I think it's like the biggest
burger that McDonald's in the UK sells
if you look at the size of this thing
it's got some heft to it it's like a
slightly more Gourmet approach as well
to Burgers than you might normally get
from McDonald's that's still a fairly
low bar because it's McDonald's however
there's I think emmental cheese on there
instead of the normal American cheese
you get the Tomato on there
and I forget what exactly is in this
sauce it's kind of similar to a Big Mac
sauce but not quite it's like a sort of
smokier and quite creamy sauce it's
really good tomatoes do not belong on
Burgers if you think they do you're
wrong
it's a really really good burger
if this stayed on the menu all year
round I probably would order this more
often big and it's tasty
they won't let him we have one festive
side and it's a cheese bites share box
these are little discs of cheese which
are breaded and deep fried they're still
ever so slightly warm I have forgotten
exactly which cheese this is I want to
say Camembert
I think it is coming back it's really
good like it's just a little disc of
cheese that's breaded and fried
and they also come with this Tangy
Tomato dip it's different to regular
ketchup it is kind of like Tangy it's
almost more of like a salsa Vibe I
really do like this as a pairing because
of it's like slightly more Tangy and
less sweet than ketchup might be I think
it kind of like cuts through the
richness of the cheese with the acidity
of the sauce I'm giving McDonald's far
too much credit here Happy Meals have
also had a festive makeover in the UK
they've been redesigned with this elf on
a shelf design
I will say Elf on the Shelf isn't really
a thing in the UK I feel like they're
trying to make it a thing with a pretty
aggressive marketing push
there are no Christmas main options in
the Happy Meal however they do have a
Christmas snack option reindeer treats
now as part of a Happy Meal in the UK
you get either like a fruit bag or in
this case a carrot bag and around
Christmas time they Rebrand it as a
reindeer treat obviously it's pretty
cute it's just a bag of carrots but
designed slightly more towards getting
kids in the Christmas spirit that said
the font that they've used for rainbow
treats really reminds me of that horror
movie The Snowman
I've got to balance out all of this
somehow cheers
that will shock you to learn this taste
of carrot
we also have two exclusive festive drink
options
they come in these actually kind of cute
Christmas themed cups here we have a
caramel waffle latte and here we have a
hot chocolate Deluxe I think the caramel
waffle latte is basically just a caramel
latte and I'm not sure what they've done
to make hot chocolate Deluxe better than
just regular hot chocolate
it's from McDonald's how Deluxe can it
really be
it's a hot chocolate it's all right
now we're on to the Domino's holiday
items there are only two items at
Domino's we've got one pizza and one
dessert this is the festive one now this
is Domino's attempt at taking a
Christmas dinner and putting it on a
pizza so this contains red onion bacon
sausage sage and onion turkey cranberry
sauce tomato and mozzarella they've gone
pretty heavy on the cranberry sauce I'm
not sure how I feel about the concept of
a Christmas dinner pizza I think certain
things on a Christmas dinner just kind
of don't belong on a pizza with Sprouts
work on a pizza yeah
foreign
I hate to admit it this is a good pizza
the cranberry sauce was the main kind of
issue I think I had with it going in but
it kind of works you know it looks like
there's a lot of it but per bite you're
not actually hearing that much and
there's enough salty things on here to
actually provide quite a nice salt and
sweet contrast maybe keep it on the menu
a little bit longer guys do your boy a
solid
the other festive menu item at Domino's
in the UK are chocolate orange cookies
when you make like a really good choc
chip cookie you kind of put like a ball
of dough on the baking tray and then it
eventually will kind of spread out when
you cook it this looks like they did
that but only cooked them halfway
chocolate and orange is actually quite a
festive flavor combination specifically
here in the UK honestly I think it's
mostly thanks to the success of the
Terry's chocolate orange but we'll talk
more about this one later
that's pretty good we do not have the
Domino's Christmas festive Pizza that
the UK has I didn't want Harry to enjoy
it all by himself so I went ahead and
got a similar Pizza this one has tomato
sauce chicken which is basically turkey
bacon Italian sausage and onions and of
course I need the cranberry dipping
sauce
oh God
it's sick
is anyone going to want to take this
pizza home after I'm done
the American version
of the UK Holiday Pizza
uh you know
it all works well together but the
cranberry sauce actually it's not that
bad
I kind of like that all right UK good
call on this
Starbucks they do it up every holiday
season I couldn't possibly get every
festive Starbucks holiday drink it's
something like 20 possibly even more I
pretty much got a drink that has one of
the core flavors they have I understand
that even though most of these are hot
except for this one you get any one of
these drinks iced mochaed
Frappuccino that I assume this is just a
sampling of what Starbucks has to offer
I don't even know what I got I just went
on the app and ordered I mean Starbucks
it's also not everything's available
everywhere so this is also everything I
could get at the local Starbucks and it
was jumping man it was jumping sugar
cookie almond milk
latte
can you just get it with regular milk
that'd be the only one I don't know but
I mean sugar cookies come on
whoa it's pretty sweet oh bro's like
stuff floating in it what is that do you
see that in there
I think like the flavor syrup or
whatever start to separate
I do like that I don't know if I could
drink a whole one of those it's like
really sweet it's got a powerful flavor
next one Chestnut praline latte we did
something pralines and it was Dreadful
let's see if Starbucks can uh can knock
out a praline drink
I would actually pick this over that
just because I could see myself
enjoying a whole grande size of that
without like getting a headache all
right Starbucks you're doing pralines
right ah
creme brulee
the flavor isn't as strong as like their
other like caramel drinks so for that
I'll say it's better than those it's
tied with this one I mean these things
are just like they're really sweet
I feel like if I drink a whole one of
those those things do a number on my
guts oh peppermint mocha let's go
fantastic peppermint mocha this is the
best one
this job rules I love being able to do
this Irish Cream cold brew
isn't Irish Cream meant to be like a hot
drink of whiskey right I'm assuming this
doesn't have any alcohol in it
let's find that together
I ever scream anything without the
alcohol nah not worth it ah toasted
white chocolate mocha cheers
this tastes like the holidays this is
really good
that is objectionable as I remember so
Starbucks took our food Wars advice and
kind of chilled out on making insane
flavored drinks and I appreciate that
thank you Starbucks also coffee
so many
signature Coffee Bean Blends that
Starbucks has I only got two the holiday
blend and the Christmas Blend wheat
Maple and herbs let's go spice chocolate
and Spruce tips all right coffee and
trees together at last so what Starbucks
has done for Christmas in the UK is
introduce four seasonal syrup flavors
and then you can use these to create a
bunch of drinks including lattes
Frappuccinos and more so what I've done
here is just get the four coffee flavors
in latte versions and then there's also
an exclusive hot chocolate I don't
really drink coffee as it is but I feel
like these barely Taste of coffee
anyways we'll start on the end with
eggnog latte I don't really know what
eggnog is still I've done a couple of
these Christmas episodes now as far as I
can tell it's like kind of nutmeggy and
slightly custody
but that's not actually too bad it's not
overly sweet you get like a little bit
of warmth from what I think is the
nutmeg honestly pleasantly surprised by
the egg mcglatte next up we've got a
toffee nut latte I don't understand why
toffee and nut as a flavor combination
is Christmassy
um oh no oh there's something wrong
there I think whatever they've used to
add the nut flavoring to this
is not working out at all for me really
kind of like attacking my tongue I'm
dressed as an elf I'm more qualified
than anyone to talk about what is and
isn't Christmassy and I'm not sure
that's Christmasy it's also just not
very nice next one is a caramel waffle
latte again not sure how Christmassy
this is exactly but it sounds pretty
good
it's basically like a big cup of milk
that someone has just kind of wafted
some waffle over don't think I would be
rushing to drink that again next one is
a gingerbread latte I will allow this
one gingerbread as a Christmasy flavor
so next up we've got a praline cookie
hot chocolate
that's so bad man
oh no that's nasty
oh how did they miss gingerbread like
that badly I'm sure there are people out
there who really love Starbucks
gingerbread I'm not trying to like pass
judgment on you or anything but Jesus
that's bad that was the last of the
latte options and I'm kind of glad to
see the back of them the last Christmas
exclusive we have in the UK is this
praline cookie hot chocolate
I don't get too much of the praline
flavor there's also little bits of like
crunchy stuff in there which I assume is
what the cookie bit is referring to I
don't know if I'd be rushing to get that
over just a standard like chocolate but
yeah decent and uh compared to some of
the coffee options really not that
offensive now while the eggnog latte
might have been my favorite
unfortunately it's also the least
healthy option on the seasonal menu
aventi eggnoglatte contains almost 500
calories as well as 52.8 grams of sugar
which is bizarre to me because honestly
it didn't taste as outright sweet as
most of the other ones now if you are a
huge fan of Starbucks's Christmas
options then good news because you can
have them at home you can get some
coffee beans and Starbucks's signature
Christmas Blends including the classic
Christmas Blend and also a blonde roast
version and if for some reason you also
liked the gingerbread or toffee nut
syrups unlike me you can also get these
at home as well although I will say they
each cost I think six pounds which seems
like a lot of money
the last at home item to test is the
color changing reusable cup we've got
some hot water here I'm going to put it
in and see if it actually does react to
it and change color
oh look at it go oh that's actually
pretty cool that worked like really fast
I don't know if I was expecting it to
work that quickly color changing cups
they they change color
yeah for the food let's go once again
this is just a small sample of the food
you can get this holiday season at
Starbucks they don't have everything
this is all the things that they had
available so that's what I got let's
start all the way down here it is of
course well reindeer pop
ah
chocolate pistachio swirl a pistachios
specifically best of a holiday themed
like really dry oh man
sugar plum Danish
why not
it's actually very good cranberry bliss
bar I mean you already know you already
know
that's always a home run it's like
cheesecake with cranberries on it so
great and of course they have festive
holiday cookies as you could see even
though I ordered it they were out I
can't be held responsible for that not
being in this video all right Starbucks
has a range of seasonal sandwiches
including a tis the season turkey
sandwich this is a turkey sandwich with
some lettuce some bacon some sage and
onions stuffing and I think some
cranberry sauce as well I don't know if
Christmas sandwiches play as much of a
role in American culture as I do in
British culture but they're like a big
deal over here basically every
supermarket chain will have their own
version of a Christmas sandwich and also
it's pretty traditional in a British
household to make sandwiches for about a
week after Christmas dinner using all
the leftover turkey and all the rest of
the stuff that you'll find on a
Christmas dinner next up we have this
Brie and cran Mary Focaccia the puns are
starting to roll in with some creamy
Brie cranberry Chutney and spinach I
love Focaccia I haven't tried Starbucks
version of Focaccia I might give this
one a try
I didn't get much of the cranberry in
that bite
it was kind of just like a bready
mouthful with a little bit of Brie I
will also say if you're in store you can
ask them to heat this up for you in like
a panini press I think it would benefit
from that we didn't do that today moving
on we have a pig's under blankets roll
they're different to American pigs and
blankets you guys consider Pigs in
Blankets those like hot dogs wrapped in
pastry in the UK it's a sausage wrapped
in bacon these are cool pigs under
blankets because I guess they didn't
want to go to the hassle of actually
wrapping the sausages in the bacon so
instead you just get sausages with a
layer of bacon on the top like a blanket
our final sandwich option is a festive
Feast Panini the festive Feast Panini
contains sliced turkey breast beef with
smoked bacon turkey gravy Sage of onion
stuffing and cranberry sauce on a
ciabatta Panini then finally Starbucks
has a bunch of Christmas baked goods so
what we have here is Starbucks's
gingerbread Barista obviously this time
he's dressed up for the holidays then
here we have a ginger mini loaf cake
it's just like a little mini ginger cake
with some kind of icing on the top
what's actually in this
it's just like a pretty standard
buttercream I think then we have a red
velvet loaf cake I think you can get
this other times of the year but for
Christmas they kind of put these
Christmas Dean sprinkles on it I know
it's basically just chocolate cake with
food dye in it but it's pretty tasty
then it's a triumphant return for the
Christmas tree brownie I think these
would look great and they taste good too
it's time the moment I've been waiting
for and I hope you all at home have been
waiting for too it's the Return of the
King it's South Pole Sam everybody he's
back third year running undefeated
champion of the Starbucks Christmas menu
he is a shortbread cookie he's covered
in chocolate the little chocolate button
for his middle bit he's so cute I love
him he's still my son I would fight to
the death for Southpaw Sam and I hope
you would too
I'm not gonna eat him I can't do it I'm
sorry he's too cute now last Christmas
we also had a North Pole nap which was a
polar bear cookie I've made up a lot of
lore in my head about South Boston North
on that having a very cute long-distance
relationship Unfortunately they didn't
have enough on that at the Starbucks we
went to today it is still on the website
so I think she is still around maybe she
and Sam are going through like a bit of
a rough patch right now in addition to
the toffee nut latte you can also get a
toffee nut muffin again I'm not
convinced on just how Christmasy toffee
nut is as a flavor combination however I
feel like this is probably going to
taste way better than the latte version
of it did
in addition to the toffee nut muffin you
can also get a toffee nut mini loaf cake
you okay my child I'm being uh peer
pressured into smelling and possibly
trying the syrups in their raw form
there's not a lot I wouldn't do for
content
this one's actually not as offensive I
don't know what was in that one which is
weird because I think I probably hated
the gingerbread latte more
um no nothing
let's talk about KFC's festive items
which are technically just one festive
item this is the gravy triple bucket
what you get with this is four orders of
fries eight spicy wings six chicken
fillets six pieces of chicken
an order of popcorn chicken and two big
things of gravy again I'm not sure what
makes this particularly festive because
all of these are things that you can
just get on the menu all year round I
think they've just kind of leaned into
making the gravy the star of the show in
this one which I guess gravy is like a
Christmas dinner thing so it does sort
of make sense but yeah not super festive
KFC if they really wanted to get festive
we've come up with the brilliant idea of
them serving turkey around Christmas I
mean imagine how great it would be if
they either sold like an entire deep
fried turkey or at least just like some
deep fried turkey wings that'd be
enormous that'd be so delicious great PR
KFC if you want to talk more you know
how to find me the only particularly
Christmasy thing about this is actually
the bucket itself they've gone for quite
a cute little Christmasy bucket design
on this side you have
Santa Claus Father Christmas himself
does he like KFC who's to say I do
absolutely love KFC gravy
I don't know what they're putting in
there I don't think I want to know pure
salt and preservatives but my God does
it taste good at our KFC you can get the
12 piece holiday bucket with six free
cookies seen here first of all six piece
of chicken in this very festive bucket
let's take a look at that cap look at
the top of that it's so festive and fun
little do you realize this bucket is
filled with cooked flesh 12 pieces in
there and
you get six biscuits yo again for
everyone in the UK this is a Biscuit in
America
two sides we went with mashed potatoes
and mac and cheese fries and as stated
six free cookies cookie Royal Flush for
you and five of your friends
yeah right you're eating all these also
this holiday season a famous bowl is
only five dollars for all of you
lonely guys
to eat alone in silence in your studio
apartments and according to kfc.com this
holiday season it's all about sharing is
caring the idea is to try to get people
to remember the joy that comes with
sitting down with folks you care about
and sharing a meal it's really that
simple what better reason to break bread
in this case chicken than the holidays
thanks KFC but I think I'll eat this
alone by myself over the course of a
weekend
Subway has one Christmas sandwich option
in the UK and it's called the festive
turkey stack
so I got this one plain without any
salad or sauces it's basically just
turkey breast hash browns and bacon
Subway in the UK do this with a few
things if they say something is a stack
on the menu all that means is that
they've added some hash browns to it is
this festive would it have killed them
to get like a little cranberry sauce or
some stuffing maybe involved
what can you say it's a sub with some
tacky some bacon and some hash browns in
it it's pretty bland currently the main
issue I'm having with this is that it's
extremely dry however
Subway has me covered
Subway UK has a seasonal sauce option
which is a pot of gravy I am
significantly less excited about this
than I would be about say KFC gravy
that's perfectly palatable gravy let's
see how it works with the sub
that's actually a significant
Improvement on the sandwich on its own
if you have both of these two things
together this actually is a pretty good
festive sub shout out to Subway
Oreos does a bunch of stuff around the
holidays I grabbed these three this one
over here very excited about
Snickerdoodle Oreos oh my God I'm gonna
kill these
yeah dude
white fudge covered oreos I mean I
grabbed it because I got the snow on
here right so I'm assuming this is
holidays right they wouldn't have the
snow packaging in July right
fantastic idea Oreo white fudge covered
oreos
yeah like this is this your oil has
snowballs
are these new and then they've ever seen
these before
I mean the packaging's a little like
just put a sticker on this and that
could have been why they have to do this
I don't packaging two of three has been
breached we're almost at the food guys
according to
package layer number one there's some
sort of like cream inside of these right
so let's keep the picture nearby that's
what we're expecting
as advertised pretty close I mean I
think they're actually pretty generous
with whatever fluffy goo they're putting
in here like it doesn't taste very good
like the epitome of just okay every year
Kit Kat
the drop the gingerbread cookie KitKat
catch happy
holidays get in there
it's like a little more Maple syrupy
than I remember we like I didn't stop by
Duncan's this year but I did at Target
see that they have the Dunkin hot
chocolate bomb it's the mint flavored
one
normally this would be submerged in hot
milk to make hot chocolate and then nice
little surprise
yo oh that's fun and they're minty every
year rhesus does something where they
just do shapes Reese's trees I mean
what do you think it's gonna look like
oh my God
it actually looks like a tree
hey
last year was like I mean we got the
Snowman of the Santa one year we got it
just looked like a total mess
ier
also got white trees I look more like a
tree than this right now Hershey's
Kisses this holiday season you get
probably more than two varieties but
these are the two they're our Target
sugar cookie oh
yep
that's kind of giving me a headache
but not bad
Chicago oh
hey fine these just taste like soft
Hershey Kisses I wasn't getting cocoa
other than just like chocolate
Twix
Santas oh it's a Santa head oh okay it's
exactly like a Twix so if you're sick of
the Twix shape you get this shape
instead
now Mary Cherry gummy bear I don't even
know if this is available outside of the
us or not I didn't look I just thought
yo I got to show this off so
one pound
of gummy
it's like when Han Solo got frozen in
carbonite or whatever it was in Star
Wars
I guess the question is like what am I
supposed to do with this would you put
this on a tray and people would just
like cut slices off of it this bear is
equal to
385 standard size gummy bears that's
really funny that they did that math so
like just this ear and part of the eye
is one
mmm
[Music]
now I understand why gummy bears come in
like small bites I have no idea what to
do with this
Jelly Belly gingerbread house kit I have
noticed over the past few years a lot of
candy brands are doing their own
gingerbread house kit sort of thing it
was the last year the year before there
was a Sour Patch Kid gingerbread ski
chalet which is actually pretty cool oh
my God
that gummy bear I have the biggest
headache now the captain Captain Crunch
has a Christmas crunch fun box fun
holiday shapes but I don't think the
flavors changed look at this like uh
color to Corn ratio it's ridiculous they
want the first bowl that comes out to be
loaded with the fun stuff so you're like
wow they're really generous and then by
the time you get like halfway through
the box you're like wait what happened
captain man what are you doing come on
you didn't work your way up
the Navy just to pull something like
this bro
for shame we thought it'd be fun to
share some iconic British Christmas
snacks with you outside of the
traditional fast food menu setting
British people absolutely love our
crisps we eat over 6 billion packets of
crisps per year which is more than the
rest of Europe put together which is
kind of crazy when you consider we only
account for maybe 10 of the population
of Europe it's become kind of a weird
tradition for British supermarkets to
come up with some very unusual flavors
around Christmas time basically they'll
take anything that could be considered a
Christmas flavor and put it on a crisp
so in the past We've Ended up with
things like Christmas tree flavored
crisps mince pie flavored crisps
Brussels sprout flavored crisps and then
today we have pigs in blankets crisps as
well as Christmas pudding crisps
I said crisps a lot there also while not
technically a crisp but pretty similar
we have these kind of cheese ball things
which in this case have been flavored
with turkey and stuffing this is such an
enormous bag as well turkey and stuffing
bites these actually look and smell
quite good
you know what
these are good I like these why are
these good
these are the ones I'm probably least
excited about
Christmas pudding crisps
smells of Christmas pudding that in
itself is quite impressive
no that's bad all you get is just like
raisin from that it's like a crunchy
raisin
last but by no means at least some pigs
and blankets flavor crisps
it's pretty low-key actually I like
these honestly while I don't want to
admit it I do think the turkey and
stuffing ball things were probably the
best of those three the next thing we
want to show you is a Christmas pudding
six month matured by Christmas Day what
is Christmas pudding well traditionally
it's a bunch of different cooked fruits
which are held together with suet suet
is I think traditionally animal fat
mixed with flour whereas this one is
vegetarian friendly so this is vegetable
that's mixed with flour this thing has
deep deep roots in British culture
people have been making this in the UK
since medieval times it also has really
deep links to Christianity and the
Christian Festival of Christmas
traditionally it had 13 ingredients
which were meant to represent Jesus and
the 12 apostles traditionally as British
households were cooking the fruit for
their Christmas pudding it would take it
in turns to stir the pot from east to
west in order to honor the Magi and
their journey in that direction
foreign
it doesn't smell too bad once the cooked
pudding is out of its mold
here comes the Brandy
now it's time for the really fun part
well for me that was great fun I don't
know how well the camera was able to
capture it but it's tradition to soak it
in alcohol and then set it on fire I'm
still not really sure what that
accomplishes I guess it adds a little
bit of flavor to it from the kind of
burning off of the alcohol but leaving
the Brandy flavor and maybe also just
like caramelizes the outside slightly
I can see the raisins in this and I have
very little interest in eating it but
here we go
I did get quite a lot of the brandy
taste which actually isn't too bad
especially once you set fire to it and
kind of burn off some of the harsher
alcohol notes it's a tradition it's a
bit of fun still not something that I
would personally choose to have as part
of my Christmas dinner we covered a
little bit of chocolate in the last
Christmas episode but we did want to
pick out just a few more classic
chocolate options around Christmas in
the UK one such option is the Ferrero
Rocher we have this giant one which I've
never actually had before and I'm kind
of intrigued to see what's inside it and
then also a box of just the regular
herreras did you know that the chocolate
stuff in this is literally just Nutella
because it's owned by the same company
these have always been marketed in the
UK as quite a fancy option and that does
kind of hold true they're quite
expensive if I ever had these in the
house growing up it was because someone
had given them to us as a gift for
example and it was quite a treat if you
got to share a box of bees on Christmas
Eve or on Christmas evening
I love the taste of chocolate and nuts
combined together so they were always up
my street
just a really delicious quite indulgent
treat Leon what's involved
Charlie
I've not actually had one of these giant
ones before and I'm really intrigued to
see what's actually in there
which was the hollow ball
I think this loses something you need
the Nutella and the nut in the middle I
think just get the regular ones last but
not least let's talk about the Terry's
chocolate orange Terry's chocolate
oranges are huge in the UK they've been
around for decades you always see them
on TV and they run up to Christmas when
they launch and people just really love
the mother hair I'm going to say
something and I've taken sick for this
in the past but I personally don't
really like Terry chocolate oranges I
just don't generally like fruit and
chocolate as a combination I'm not
trying to take them away from anyone
else you can enjoy what you want to
enjoy however not really for me so
Terry's had a series of adverts with
comedian Dawn French now the marketing
slogan is always don't tap it whack it
because what you get is basically a ball
of chocolate but it is split into
segments kind of representing an orange
the idea is that to separate these you
just give it a good whack
[Music]
although it technically isn't an
exclusive item this holiday season Pepsi
at least in the U.S has really been
pushing for this idea or this thing
called pilk which is Pepsi and milk they
even have an AG campaign with Lindsay
Lohan
where you guessed it she is mixing Pepsi
and milk and it seems like on Twitter
they're even trying to encourage other
people to mix Pepsi with milk or vanilla
creamer to make pilk recipes she doesn't
actually drink it she combines it she
goes for sip they cut to a shot of seven
they cut back and she's like yum I
really don't want to do this I feel like
it's gonna make me nauseous so what do
you think should I do the Pepsi and then
the milk or the milk and the Pepsi it
looks like you have Pepsi first and then
the milk but then you didn't drink it
see uh hang on
I'm typing in pilk recipe like like
does that work yeah everyone online is
like this is a nightmare
and as you are aware whenever someone
says something on the Internet it's true
and we should believe it
I'm going Pepsi than milk because that's
how low hand did it
uh
milk is gross
do we like this pill consistency or
should I should I milk my pilk more
I don't think that's very good at all it
isn't strong but the flavor it's kind of
just like weak Pepsi that's a little
creamier
foreign
but you guys are gonna do some r d and
actually bottle something new they're
making us make the drinks at home now
the hell's that no Pepsi no
to pilk no pilk pilk is bad don't drink
milk
Merry Christmas you filthy animals